[Music]
on this saturday night canadian cities
sweltering the summer scorchers sweeping
through the prairies and western ontario
while some regions of b.c burned we've
been through this last year and it's
bringing up lots of anxiety and parts of
europe deal with an unrelenting heat
wave that's claimed hundreds of lives
plus passport problems persist the
lineup outside the passport office was
all around the mall and almost outside
the door why the feds feel they can fix
the backlog as time runs out for
families waiting to travel soldier saved
why this ukrainian woman whose mother
was shot dead helped rescue a russian
fighter and from chuckwagon controversy
this is kind of interesting i've never
been at a weekday powwow to increased
inclusivity and sold out shows the
biggest party of the summer heads into
its final weekend
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight mithu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
many canadians are seeking out air
conditioning this weekend as
temperatures have climbed into the 30s
prompting environment canada to issue
heat warnings for large parts of alberta
saskatchewan manitoba and ontario while
in bc the forest fire situation has
quickly escalated homes have been
destroyed and a number of evacuation
orders are now in place abigail beeman
reports on the impact of the first major
heat wave of the summer and what we can
expect over the coming weeks
stressed stress
we've been through this last year and
it's bringing up lots of anxiety a year
after fire destroyed linton bc dozens
there are under an evacuation order
trying to do what they can to process
the repeat threat we can bring water we
can bring meals to the firefighters you
know they're going to be working
12 14 16 hour days here the fire is
still out of control but there is
positive news the reports are from the
ground or that the fire activity
overnight was quite minimal
so there's limited growth the worry now
next week's climbing temperatures
a northern manitoba first nation is
facing evacuations too with the
administration trying to help families
via facebook
we were the last group that left
pacquiao and we followed the railroad
tracks all the way to the ball and then
we were all put up in either the power
cranberry in a gymnasium much of
manitoba and saskatchewan as well as
southern alberta and northern ontario
are under heat warnings from environment
canada with some daytime highs as hot as
36 degrees celsius and humidex values
close to 40. in some areas there's no
reprieve for three days
we found that our ice cream sandwiches
were kind of starting to heat up and
melt a little bit so we had to put a
hold on those well relief from the heat
is expected across the prairies in the
coming days but that comes with a cold
front the moisture needed with showers
and thunderstorms but not the lightning
and wind and there could also be more
storms around linton this weekend too
and in regions with no heat warnings
like the nation's capital people were
still looking for ways to beat the heat
this and ice cream
staying hydrated
and
make sure i put on some sunscreen it
honestly it's not as bad as the first
time i worked here i think i'm just used
to it now environment canada predicts we
won't see as much deadly heat this
summer as in 2021 but expects we will
see summers like that one more often in
the years to come and even if things
don't get as hot this summer nearly the
entire country is expected to see
temperatures higher than normal except
bc
abigail beeman global news ottawa
a heat wave sweeping across europe is
being blamed for more than 300 deaths
thousands of people have been forced to
leave their homes as firefighters tried
to control the flames the fires are
stretching from the central parts of
spain out to the southwest of france
temperatures in portugal have soared
above 46 degrees celsius and tomorrow is
forecast to be even hotter
the british government is holding an
emergency meeting ahead of those record
high temperatures expected to hit next
week for the first time a red warning
has been issued saying the extreme heat
may pose a risk to healthy people and
could cause serious illness or even
death the alert covers most of england
for monday and tuesday when temperatures
are forecast to climb above 40 degrees
the area of high pressure currently
sitting over the uk will progressively
move east across
north central europe and reach the
northern balkans by the middle of next
week this will result in high
temperatures for much of western central
europe
rail systems are being advised to halt
travel during peak heat hours while care
homes are being told to take extra
precautions to protect the elderly
as the travel restrictions fell away the
desire of canadians to travel took off
from april 1st to the end of june
service canada received more than 808
000 applications for passports that
surge in demand has led to a massive
backlog with many canadians wondering if
they'll have their documents in time to
travel shalima maharaj has the latest
we were told originally maybe four to
six weeks we'd have the passport we
hadn't heard anything prompting oshawa
ontario resident chris vale to pay a
visit to his local passport office i
went in at about 6 15 in the morning
only to figure out that the lineup
outside the passport office was all
around the mall and almost outside the
door i was about 200 people deep the
passport is for their one-year-old
daughter they're heading east to see
family for the first time in a long time
and were planning on detouring through
the states it wasn't until nine weeks
after he and his wife started the
process that they were finally able to
get some answers to her credit she was
able to stick with it and then she was
finally able to to get through vale says
his wife was informed that until that
moment their application had never even
been looked at
so i sent it off registered mail on may
20th
the government received it may 25th my
credit card was charged june 15th for
the 257 dollar processing fees
and now at this point i have no idea
what's going on
time is running out for calgary resident
trevor boudreau who booked a trip to
south carolina so his girls could spend
time with their grandfather i haven't
even received a response to
my request for a status update at this
point canadians under 16 traveling to
the u.s by land or sea are allowed to
present an original copy of their birth
certificate something boudreaux and many
other canadians mailed in to get their
children's passports renewed i thought i
was being responsible by giving them you
know between the third week of may to
the end of the first week of august
families minister karina gould says she
remains confident the backlog can be
dealt with in four to six weeks
we're also working on a notification
system
that hopefully will be rolling out in
the next week or so to keep people who
provided their contact details in the
loop on its progress gould says if your
travel is not urgent visit your local
service canada if it is meaning you're
leaving in the next week or so bring
your proof of travel with you so if that
is an airline ticket if you're traveling
by air if you're traveling by land it
can be a hotel reservation that you have
in the united states
and go to that passport office as for
chris vale his daughter's passport is
now on track to being ready for pick up
next week just being able to finally go
on this trip go see some family after so
long and being closed off from so many
people and the people we loved it's just
it's a blessing for us
shaleema maharaj global news toronto
u.s president joe biden has wrapped up
his four-day visit to the middle east
with assurances america won't neglect
the region while so much focus has
shifted to russia's war against ukraine
with u.s gas prices reaching record
highs biden also came away with promises
for more mideast oil production to help
combat ballooning inflation jennifer
johnson has more
after meetings with the leaders of egypt
iraq and the united arab emirates u.s
president joe biden pledged a stronger
relationship with the middle east as
other superpower nations threaten
regions throughout the world the united
states is going to remain an active
engaged partner in the middle east we
will not walk away
and leave a vacuum to be filled by
china russia or iran the president's
visit to saudi arabia has drawn harsh
criticism from republicans and the widow
of former washington post columnist
jamal khashoggi who was a frequent
critic of the kingdom biden met with
saudi crown prince mohammed bin salman
who u.s intelligence concluded was
behind khashoggi's murder when you're
president you got to deal with people
you don't like as well as people you do
like and we have an alignment of
interest biden did send a direct message
to the crown prince and others in the
region stressing the importance of human
rights and freedom of speech the future
will be won by the countries that
unleash the full potential of their
populations where citizens can question
and criticize their leaders without fear
of reprisal biden and the kingdom did
negotiate an increase of saudi oil
production
the u.s has seen the highest gas prices
in history since the president took
office hitting americans hard i had
plans of traveling
the northern part of the united states
this year but
can't do it to fuel prices
prices have decreased slightly over the
past two weeks and the president says
the saudis increase production will
further help lower costs in another few
weeks but that's not soon enough for
many americans it's incredibly sad to
say oh look it's only 5 59 over here and
we're excited about it with inflation
hitting a 40-year high back home biden
made his first middle east visit as
president the white house is looking for
a win as polls show biden's job approval
numbers continue to plummet
disagreements over the war in ukraine
kept the g20 finance ministers from
issuing their usual formal communique
when they wrapped up a series of
meetings in indonesia the ministers are
urging all countries to take urgent
action to tackle inflation and address
the growing global food insecurity
crisis
the unresolved profit 19 pandemic as
well as the unfolding war in ukraine
are likely to exacerbate the already
severe 2022 acute food in security that
we are already seeing
the g20 includes western countries like
canada that have imposed sanctions on
russia and accused it of war crimes in
ukraine as well as nations like china
india and south africa which have been
more muted in their responses to the
invasion
the u.s and russian space agencies have
struck a deal to fly each other's
astronauts to the international space
station the news comes as an unmanned
spacex dragon capsule docked with the
station delivering more than 2600
kilograms of supplies to the
multinational crew in orbit the
agreement will allow for an american
astronaut to travel to the station with
two russian cosmonauts aboard a russian
soyuz rocket in september while another
russian will be aboard a spacex launch
that same month with two americans and a
japanese astronaut
coming up a ukrainian woman's survival
story and how she saved a russian
soldier
russian forces keeping up their barrage
of artillery and missile attacks
targeting civilian infrastructure in
eastern ukrainian cities overnight this
commercial warehouse in the key port
city of odessa was hit by rockets which
set the building on fire keeves says
moscow has been intensifying attacks on
civilian targets far from the front line
a claim the kremlin has repeatedly
denied
we are in the fifth month of russia's
attack on ukraine and since the invasion
began time and time again civilians have
been the targets of horrifying attacks
and atrocities in the early days of the
invasion russian soldiers were ordered
to fire on civilians traveling on a
roadway but one of the women who was
shot at survived she's alive because
some soldiers didn't follow through on
the order to kill and in turn she saved
a russian soldier's life when he got
shot shawn o'shea reports from ukraine
the war here in ukraine has lasted more
than four months but back in february on
its first day carolina perlifon came
face to face with death that's when
russian soldiers on a roadway in eastern
ukraine opened fire on the car she was
in with her mother irena
her 51 year old mother was wounded hit
by a bullet in the head she died there
on the spot carolina was her only child
in those minutes carolina thought she
was dead too recording and later posting
this video to instagram thanking her
parents for giving her life
you hear the gunfire in the background
but carolina survived the roadside
attack partly because two russian
soldiers including this man refused to
carry out their orders to kill
ukrainians there on the spot
[Music]
the lieutenant colonel gave the order to
shoot civilians this soldier told
ukrainian interrogators after his
capture authorities shared the video
with carolina
she's still processing what happened
that day those soldiers could have
killed you at that time couldn't they
mug
instead the young soldiers were soon hit
by gunfire one died and this soldier was
injured he was bleeding and couldn't
walk
then perhaps an even more remarkable act
than the soldier's decision not to kill
as her mother laid dead from a russian
bullet carolina drove the young russian
soldier to safety why did you do that
taking the soldier 10 minutes away to
get medical attention she realized he
survived when she saw the interrogation
video
he would have died she told us i
wouldn't have been able to live and i
know i had a chance to save him he's a
human he didn't do anything to me the
29-year-old lawyer who lost her mother
to russians who targeted civilians still
coping with her loss and confident she
did what was right
sean o'shea global news near kharkiv
ukraine
a tumultuous week in sri lanka has ended
with the country's parliament accepting
the resignation of the president from
exile overseas the streets of colombo
are now calm after months of protests
over runaway inflation shortages of
basic goods and government corruption
boiled over this week with people
storming government buildings and the
presidential palace and causing gotabaya
rajapaksa to flee a new president will
be chosen next week a fresh start that
sri lankans are hoping will begin the
process of easing the island's economic
process and rebuild trust in its
shattered politics
ahead cutting back costs while
increasing your income expert tips on
navigating soaring inflation
the bank of canada surprised economists
with a one percent key interest rate
hike amid soaring inflation which has
many canadians reconsidering their
spending habits with a look at some
practical tactics and strategies
households can take on to navigate the
next few months of cutbacks and
uncertainty financial counselor pamela
george is joining us now so pamela
what's your advice to those who are
panicking over the possibility they
might not be able to afford their
mortgage
my advice first of all is to take a
breath
calm down don't panic
and
don't try to do it by yourself it's not
a diy situation right now seek
professional help
now there could be more interest
increases this year how are you
preparing clients to plan ahead for the
higher cost of living
well the fact that we know there's going
to be more interest rates increases i
think it's a good thing in the sense
that they have given us a heads up so
it's a good time to look at your budget
look and see where you can decrease some
costs eliminate some altogether if you
have to it's not going to be forever but
look at your budget reduce what you can
put it aside for when those increase
rates come back maybe in a couple months
late late in the year that type of thing
what about those on fixed incomes how
can they manage household costs with
runaway inflation
well you know fixed income that's what
it is but
i feel we can always look at ways to
find something on the side to do yes you
bring in you know four thousand dollars
a month however there are things you can
do let's say your your expenses are up
500 a month because of all these
increased prices well that's 125 dollars
a week find a side gig find something
that you can do to bring in that money
and it's not just
finding employment it might be that you
have a skill you have some talent that
you can look into and start bringing in
you know start a small business a gig
put something on etsy and sell it i've
seen that happen with my clients and it
works regardless of financial situation
and debt what are some overall
strategies around spending less or even
earning more that you'd recommend right
now
well
you know it i always say times like this
you need to look at your budget but
having a mindset of i am going to make
this happen there's nothing that will
change this right now but there's a i
feel there's a lot we can still do and a
lot we still have in our control that we
could employ in order to see
you know to help us through this to help
us ride the waves and some of them like
i said it's increasing income but it's
really looking at it from a
a
from a way that we can we can say okay
at the end of this i am going to come
out of it better or at least how i went
in and not worse i think just shifting
at that mindset a little bit is going to
help us not go into that sinking
mentality and mindset that i'm seeing
all over social media right now
financial counselor pamela george pamela
thank you so much
thank you very much
next the star-studded celebrations as
the calgary stampede rallies a business
bounce back
the calgary stampedes star-studded event
wrapping up this weekend the event which
builds itself as the greatest outdoor
show on earth pulling out all the stops
for its post pandemic protocol return
attracting actors politicians and
visitors from around the world as tracy
nagai reports the attendance numbers
proving it will take more than a
pandemic to dampen calgary's stampede
spirit
from hollywood movie stars it's always
nice to be invited anywhere
to wild west rodeos
the stampede once again drawing in
tourists from across canada and around
the world showcasing long time favorites
and new events
i'm from the united states so this is
kind of interesting i've never been at a
weekday powwow
this year's celebration of cowboy
culture highly anticipated following
health restrictions and pandemic
protocols we're tracking very close
to 2019 attendance levels which was a
fantastic year
the soaring temperatures and prices on
the midway no match for people wanting
to soak it all in we've had
an extremely hard year
so especially the last couple months so
it's really important to just yeah
to get a day that's like don't think
about it just go have fun we're supposed
to come in 2020 when it got canceled
so the trip got pushed back a few years
but we're excited and happy to be out
and the economic benefits are being
welcomed by businesses that have
struggled over the last few years hotels
the restaurants the attractions people
are out and they are spending money and
they're enjoying themselves in the city
right now it's wonderful to see to have
it gone for so long it definitely felt
like there was a void in the city so
when they announced it it was like
we're ready we're ready
however the 10-day event not without
controversy with renewed calls from
animal advocacy groups to end the chuck
wagon races following the death of a
horse despite new safety measures this
year we're still seeing this carnage and
we're still seeing another dead horse we
are doing a tremendous amount to help
minimize any incidents that might occur
unfortunately we can't eliminate all
risk with the 2022 calgary stampede in
the books the hope the buzz will remain
long after the greatest outdoor show on
earth is over
tracy nagai global news calgary
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm nitu garcia tonight's
your canada is squirrel cove on cortez
island in bc we love seeing your canada
please keep emailing your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching have a great night
[Music]
you